[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
1er mars parole à catherine helayel co
organisatrice du rassemblement citoyen
prévu demain devant l'abattoir de houdan
alors que les actions se multiplient
depuis la diffusion d'imagés les
accusations de maltraitance portée par
l'association l214 envers la bâtard
yvelinois parole aussi à lionel masse et
à le directeur du théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il dévoilera
le programme des rencontres et insiter
un mélange d'art et de science pour
évoquer l'importance et vague
problématique du temps mais on débute
donc cette émission avec vous catherine
helayel bonsoir bonsoir helayel excusez
moi vous êtes co organisatrice du
rassemblement je le disais citoyen qui a
lieu demain en fin d'après-midi devant
l'abattoir de ou dont on va replacer un
peu tout ça dans le contexte l'abattoir
qui est dans l'actualité depuis à peu
près quelques semaines et notamment
depuis la mi-février et la divulgation
des images choquantes où l'on voit deux
clairement des ports frappé pour les
pousser vers l'abattage des images qu'on
voit à l'instant des images tournées fin
décembre par l'association l214 connu
pour avoir dévoilé ce type d'affaires
plusieurs fois
alors ma première question est ce que
vous êtes totalement indépendants ou
alors c'est en soutien avec
l'association l214 le rassemblement qui
est prévue demain alors le rassemblement
est totalement indépendant c'est à dire
il est hors associations puisqu'il a été
organisé par des citoyens donc on ne
souhaitait pas ce que ce soit une
association qui j'allais dire même
le rassemblement mais il est évident
qu'on a le soutien de l214 on a le
soutien d'autres associations
mais c'est pas c'est un mouvement
citoyen déclarée en préfecture salle
faiblement légal écoutez on ne sait pas
c'est compliqué c'est difficile mais on
espère comme le rassemblement va durer
plusieurs heures puisqu'il commence à 17
heures pour se terminer à une heure du
matin
il risque d'y avoir au moins 150 à 200
personnes mais entre 17 heures il va y
avoir un roulement je pense pas qu'on
sera tous ensemble au même moment mais
on espère être nombreux alors expliquez
nous quel est l'objectif de ce
rassemblement quel message vous voulez
pas reporter qu'est ce que vous voulez
dénoncer concrètement alors en fait le
message au départ et devait être un
message tournant symbolique c'est à dire
que quand que l'on soit vegan
végétariens ou haut niveau auront peu
importe ce qu'on voulait avant tout
dénoncer c'est toutes les violences que
l'on quitte kiki qui sont exercées sur
les animaux dans les abattoirs
que les gens arrêtent de penser que
c'est exceptionnel parce qu'en fait il
n'y a pas de mort douce il ya toujours
des violences dans les abattoirs mais
aussi ce rassemblement n'est pas un
rassemblement qui est dirigée contre
contre une catégorie de personnes sert
quand c'est pas un rassemblement dirigé
contre les salariés des abattoirs contre
les éleveurs mais c'est un système que
l'on dénonce un système qui pousse
effectivement 90% et des animaux à être
élevés de manière intensive avec tué
dans des conditions terribles et ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que les images
que l'on voit
dans cet abattoir on voit les cochons
qui sont effectivement frappé il y en a
même qui sont frappés avec des bâtons
d'électricité dans les yeux ce n'est que
le début de leur calvaire puisque ces
cautions sont dirigés ensuite vers ce
qu'on appelle un puits de co2 terre qui
vont être gazés alors la presse les
éleveurs aime bien utiliser le mot
endormi mais nous avons eu la gratouille
ou grâce à ses deux sens quatre sénégal
c'est par gazage ce gazage est
parfaitement légal d'ailleurs l214 avait
aussi dans l'abattoir d'alès réussi à
mettre une caméra qui est descendu dans
la fosse à co2 et on voit les cochons
qui se tordre ils sont asphyxiés ils
sont il ya des convulsions c'est une
meuf c'est un endormissement qui est
lent qui est douloureux et il arrive
souvent qu'après cet endormissement les
cochons se réveille sur la chaîne
d'abattage est ce que ça veut dire que
concrètement vous êtes contre la fin
totale de l'abattage des animaux de la
consommation des animaux c'est notamment
un projet ça qui est porté par
l'association l214 est-ce que c'est
aussi le but d'un tel rassemblement est
ce que ça va encore plus loin
alors je ne vais pas parler au nom de
l214 je ne peux pas parler non plus en
mon nom puisque bien évidemment j'ai
aussi des convictions le ce
rassemblement n'a pas pour but premier
bien évidemment de dire de la fin des
abattoirs sépare rassemblement idéologie
noualhat même si il est clair que pour
sa suivante on est là pour arrêter là
toute la souffrance puisque bon dénonce
aussi le mythe de la viande heureuse
à terme on souhaite effectivement on
aimerait la fin des abattoirs mais avant
d'en arriver là et c'est pour ça qu'on
on pense qu'il faudrait même travail et
pourquoi pas un jour j'allais dire non
avec les éleveurs pour une reconversion
trouver des méthodes
commencez à vous voyez regardez vous
avez même par exemple les fabricants qui
vante souvent des produits carnés comme
les jambons
mais comme des côtelettes ont commencé à
distribuer dans les magasins des
produits à base de végétaux
donc il faut parallèlement soutenir une
filière par exemple qui commencerait à
faire du végétal des légumineuses pour
revenir sur l'abattoir de houdan
l'association l214 a porté plainte
récemment au tribunal de grande instance
de versailles est ce que aussi ce
rassemblement c'est pour les soutenir
est-ce que vous souhaitez par exemple
cet abattoir soit fermée puisque ait eu
de tels agissements est ce que c'est une
revendication aussi de votre part ou pas
du tout si je voulais que cet abattoir
soit fermé parce qu'il se passe des
choses atroces dans cet abattoir
ça voudrait dire qu'il faudrait fermer
tous les abattoirs parce que cet
abattoir c'est pas une exception
ça se passe comme ça dans tous les
abattoirs vous avez sans doute entendu
parler de mauricio vous savez ce lanceur
d' alerte qui a dénoncé ce qui se
passait avec les vaches les vaches
gestantes à limoges et bien aujourd'hui
mauricio dénonce en fait des cadences
infernales c'est c'est tout c'est tout
un système qu'on dénonçait pas cet
abattoir et d'ailleurs les éleveurs nous
disent que ils veulent soutenir cet
abattoir en danger mais c'est pas demain
oui et bien mettons en danger nous il y
avait un rassemblement justement jeudi
dernier en soutien à l'abattoir je vous
propose d'écouter la réaction du pdg de
l'abattoir qui était présent jeudi
dernier tout a été fait chez nous pour
que ça se reproduise plus tout était
déjà fait mais là on a ra mis les
bouchées doubles j'ai quelques employés
conquis sont pas loin de la dépression
donc enfin surtout les ceux qui sont les
plus impliqués un peu et qui sont au
commerce c'était assez difficile
bon moi ça fait déjà un mois que je
je me blinde mais bon c'était aussi
difficile pour ma famille on reçoit des
mails d'insultés pour soi fin des belles
choses quoi plein de choses qui sont pas
forcément nous on est là pour bosser on
essaie de le faire le mieux possible
voilà donc je suis très content du
soutien de
de tous mes partenaires mes amis et de
tous ceux qui qui qui sont pas forcément
d'accord avec ces gens là
harang c'est une cible assez facile il
ya d'autres abattoirs
je ne citerai pas les noms ou ça ça peut
être beaucoup plus difficile pour eux
mais moi je me tiendrai à continuer à
faire mon métier jusqu'au bout de la
meilleure façon
alors il nous reste peu de temps on va
rien insisté sur cette volonté de ne pas
faire monter les choses vous ne visez
pas spécifiquement un homme puisqu'on
parlait la double menace on vise pas un
homme
ou vous ne visez pas des personnes
précisément vous visez vous ramener un
système est bien évidemment en tant que
co organisatrice d'un tel rassemblement
en tant que militante je suis
complètement formellement farouchement
opposées à toute menace à toute action
agressive
nous sommes des pacifiques nous nous
savons très bien que c'est pas en
agressant et en insultant les personnes
que l'on va changer de modèle de société
une dernière réaction sur une loi qui
était voté récemment par l'assemblée
nationale qui prévoit qu'au 1er janvier
2018 tous les établissements de découpe
froncés 960 au total doivent avoir
doivent être équipées de vidéo
surveillance savage imagine dans un sens
qui que vous souhaiter un bon sens ou
alors vous lever les yeux au ciel riz
non me paraît complètement convaincre et
à titre personnel elle répondrait pas
simplement se dire est que en fait la
loi et f à la proposition était vidé de
sa substance puisque en fait ces caméras
ne seront vus que par les j'allais dire
par les parties à dire qu'il faut aller
plus loin il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin
merci catherine helayel pour toutes ces
précisions merci d'être venus en plateau
et on poursuit cette 8è les invités avec
de la science et de l'art un mélange
prévu lors des rencontres in cité
l'événement qui se déroulera au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 18 au 26
mars à cette occasion nous avons
rencontré lionel masse et à le directeur
du théâtre pour faire un point sur cette
initiative on les couteaux micro
d'haussmann vendeurs d alors pourquoi
avoir décidé de mélanger j'imagine que
ça a un lien ou par rapport à paris
saclay ce côté art et aussi ce côté
science plutôt sa main pour une raison
qui moi me paraît évidente je sais pas
si elle est pour tout le monde sait que
j'ai le sentiment mais peut-être parce
que ce sont des matières qui m'intéresse
mais que ce soit le citoyen les citoyens
nous ou bien les artistes nous sommes de
plus en terrain de plus en plus
intéressés par ce que ce qui relève du
champ scientifique
peut-être que l'on a tout simplement
besoin de comprendre la complexité du
monde
on est dans un dans une société de plus
en plus complexes que l'on a souvent du
mal à décoder et je pense que l'attrait
aussi bien pour les sciences dures que
pour les sciences humaines est une façon
de tenter de décoder cette société dans
laquelle on vit cette société que l'on
composé que l'on construit avec nos vies
et je rajouterais autre chose pourquoi
le lien avec l'art parce que les
artistes ne sont pas restés étrangers à
cet attrait cette attirance pour pour
les champs scientifiques et ses champs
scientifiques soient sont les points de
départ de certains spectacles soient
sont véritablement les sujets de
certains spectacles
il va y avoir non seulement de
spectacles quatre spectacles spectacle
de cirque spectacle de danse musique et
théâtre le spectacle de 2,2 un spectacle
tête qui s'appelle corps diplomatique
qui est un voyage dans le temps d'une
d'une troupe de théâtre qui part à bord
de la station spatiale jean vilar
spéciale spectacle assez très documenté
et extrêmement drôle sur sur dessus sur
justement cette question du voyage dans
le temps et comment est-ce que l'on
réagit artistes lorsqu'on a un temps
infini pour créer un spectacle
est-ce que l'urgence n'est pas
absolument nécessaire à la création des
spectacles et l'ice roxette compagnie va
avoir des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années pour créer un spectacle que
va-t-il se passer
il ya un spectacle de cirque auquel je
tiens très particulièrement qui
s'appelle aléas qui ont spectacle à la
fois sur la lenteur et sur cette
question de la gravité et donc du vide
c'est un spectacle de chloé
l'ia qui va descendre qui est une
trapéziste et qui va descendre sur une
quarantaine de minutes
un filin d'acier de 40 mètres donc à la
force des bras et se filin d'acier
passera au dessus des spectateurs et
elle nous fait ressentir que ce que l'on
considère comme le vide et finalement
plein de quelque chose et nous donne une
idée totalement différent du vide et ce
spectacle sera les deux soirs suivie par
une conférence improvisée en grande
partie du physicien philosophe et
journaliste
etienne klein et pour finir sur cette
partie des questions dites moi les saint
quentinois ils seront au rendez vous ils
sont prêts à l'art science ben je
l'espère parce que j'ai dit que nous
étions partis nous souhaitons aborder
cette thématique par le biais de la
science physique il va y avoir une
dizaine de scientifiques de tout premier
plan qui sont également des
vulgarisateurs hors pair il va y avoir
des physiciens mais il va y avoir
également des philosophes des neuro
anatomiste des biologistes parce que
lorsqu'on parle du temps on pense aussi
au voyage dans le temps or le voyage
dans le temps ce n'est pas que le voyage
physique dans le temps et qu'il a été
imaginé par beaucoup de réalisateurs
mais c'est aussi un voyage à travers la
mémoire à travers la géologie à travers
la théorie de l'évolution
donc ces conférences c'est vraiment
quelque chose auquel on tient
elles ont été conçues elles ont été
pensées avec un astrophysicien qui
travaille au cea de saclay qui s'appelle
roland lehoucq et puis va y avoir
également un côté de ces conférences de
ses spectacles une partie si nos
graphismes cinématographique arts en
partenariat avec l'ugc qui est juste à
côté avec son directeur marc allemand
grave et c'est la fin du set 8 les
invités pour ce soir prochain rendez
vous demain bonne soirée à tous sur tv
fil 78
[Musique]